prince william was right by his
grandmother's side on her first trip to
scotland
since the death of prince philip
the original recipe the prince joined
the queen for a week of royal duties
for the first time since the death of
her husband of 73 years
in april
the 39 year old duke of cambridge and
the queen kicked off monday at the soda
maker
ag bars factory in cumbernauld just
trying to guess what's in it that's
quite hard isn't it
the queen helped to officially open the
new facility then she and william were
given a rundown on the history of the
140 year old company
and they met the employees the two also
traveled to the official royal residence
of
hollywood house in edinburgh for the
ceremony of the keys
the traditional welcome ceremony at the
royal residence where queen elizabeth
was
officially welcomed to the scottish
capital and given the keys of the city
afterward the royals met local
volunteers and first responders to thank
them for their efforts during the
pandemic
and while william is with the queen on
monday according to the palace
her daughter princess anne will be by
the queen's side on wednesday and
thursday
[Music]
of course this all comes amid the royal
family's effort to repair their internal
rift
following prince harry and meghan
markle's explosive interview with oprah
winfrey earlier this year
the brothers are set to reunite at a
small event to mark the unveiling of a
statue they commissioned in honor of
their late mother princess diana on july
1st a day which would have been diana's
60th birthday
this event in july is much anticipated
the unveiling of the diamond statue is
going to be an
important date it's firmly cemented in
both of the brothers calendars
a source previously told et that harry
is back in the uk
at frogmore cottage the windsor
residence where he and his wife
lived before stepping away from their
royal roles in early 2020.
at the time the source explained quote
prince harry will land in the uk
and isolate for five days before taking
a covet test
affirming that he is negative before the
events of the day
diana always said to them boys stay
close
don't ever fall out she would be
devastated that that is what happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
a source also previously told et that
megan will not attend the unveiling of
the statue
since she just gave birth to their
daughter lillabet diana
earlier this month meanwhile royal
expert katie nicholl told et in
april that while harry and william still
have a long way to go when it comes to
repairing their relationship
the unveiling of the statue of their
late mother is a step in the right
direction
the idea that harry's suddenly going to
come around to william's way of thinking
and vice versa
i think is is a way off i think there do
need to be
more conversations there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts so it's early days
but i think the hope is that
come july when we are hoping to see the
brothers stand
once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil the statue in memory of their
mother
that the relationship will be stronger
and in a better place